what's more likely heading into week
nine the fulcrum you know what a fulcrum
is
and i don't think i do i feel like i've
heard the word but what does it mean
the fulcrum is like the absolute
midpoint so we've got eight weeks on
each side week nine is the full right
because we got 17. so week nine the
fulcrum of the season we've gotten here
that's the good news when we get to the
end who knows we only hope that it works
out let's get ready for the games to
come this week with a what's more likely
exercise seahawks six and one at the six
and two bills
what's more likely your boy blue josh
allen gets back to an mvp level
performance or the seahawks defense
carries over last week's pretty good
game against the 49ers yes yeah this is
uh it was it was a pretty damn good game
for the 49ers but this is a different
matchup and i think this is a matchup
that is
not as good for the seahawks as it was
last week you know the thing that was
that played into the seahawks last week
is they're not bad at run defense
they'll sell out to stop the run and of
course we know the 49ers want to run the
football and their drop back pass game
is not special well it's like the
opposite this week this is a special
drop back pass game and this is a
quarterback who's got some weapons to go
along with it and a pretty good creative
offensive coordinator and then i look at
like you know still lack of pass rush
with the seattle seahawks and things
like that to me this is where josh allen
can create time and do that i'm gonna go
josh allen gets back to mvp like level i
don't know if that translates into them
winning the game
but i think he'll play a really good
football game put up big stats and gonna
look more like the guy we saw earlier in
the year than as compared to the last
you know four games where it's been a
little up and down and they've had some
struggles
first four games incredibly impressive
they won all of them then they lost two
in a row and it feels like they've been
fighting for the last two weeks to get
out of that funk here's josh allen
talking yesterday about facing the
seahawks this weekend
we understand how how well the seahawks
are playing and how well um you know the
quarterback uh russell wilson is playing
there and um you know we got no small
task now you know this coming week
they're um you know top in a lot of
statistical categories on the offensive
side of the ball and we got to make sure
that we're doing our part and trying to
keep them off the field as much as
possible but um you know they got some
very opportunistic guys on defense and
they're forcing a lot of turnovers so
it's it's going to be a four quarter dog
fight we understand that
it's good to know that josh allen is old
enough to grow a beard i think that's
the first time he sported that look
double take though yeah yeah so uh
getting ready for the winner in buffalo
got to keep the face warm in uh one of
the quarter areas of the country it's
gonna be a fun game look
yeah well it is gonna be a fun game
because number one
we're waiting for the bills to wake up
again and this is going to be one of the
tougher opponents they face the rest of
the way number two jamal adams full go
at practice on wednesday for the first
time
in five and a half weeks since he
suffered the groin strain against the
cowboys way back in week three he had a
limited practice last friday he had an
illness on top of the groin issue
full practice this week hasn't played
full practice wednesday is a pretty
clear sign that barring some sort of a
setback or an aggravation he'll be good
to go on sunday which will make it
harder for josh allen to get back to his
mvp level performance no no doubt i mean
jamal adams is he's special we saw that
the first few weeks of the year and you
know they've put them in some tough
spots and ask them to do a lot of a lot
of tough things as far as the safety is
concerned but uh yeah i would think that
there's
an emphasis on getting jamal allen's
jamal adams to be a blitzer this week or
be around the line of scrimmage to oh
josh allen broke out of the pocket now
you go spy or run him down and be that
guy i think you could see that a lot
this week it'd be interesting and also
going to see carlos dunlap this week too
right
that'll be another interesting wrinkle
in the game too just to see where that
goes
the uh arizona cardinals are hosting the
miami dolphins it's kyler murray versus
tuatanga vialoa they have a little bit
of a history from their college days
crossing paths when kyler was at
oklahoma and two was at alabama here's
tua talking about the quarterback he'll
be facing this weekend
i'm very excited to go up against him
i would say first impressions when i
when i met him
he's
you know he's pretty jacked up you know
for for as you know short as he is he's
he's i mean this guy's rocked up um but
he he's very competitive um
you know he's very personable too i got
to meet his parents as well at the
heisman ceremony very good family
you know but against going against guys
like that who are very competitive and
you know you're going to get their best
i i think that's going to be a fun one
i like how tua was as diplomatic as
possible he wanted to say he's really
short because he is but that just makes
his skill set even more impressive and
it makes it even more fun to watch kyla
murray and here's the fundamental
difference kyler has proven it over and
over again to a the jury's still out
yeah because last week it was more about
the defense than it was about tuatanga
by law so what's more likely this week
dolphins four and three at the five and
two cardinals brian flores the miami
coach contains kyle murray or tua airs
it out for the dolphins to be successful
oh
i i
i think i'm going to go with door number
one on this one i i think brian flores
will contain kyler murray i do you know
one we saw matt patricia and detroit
have the right game plan right and again
of course they were coaching together in
new england you know after new england
got torched by desean watson his rookie
year and scrambling and everything like
that
they really after that came up with
plans to
limit
quarterbacks who can move a lot from
running around extending plays and doing
that what desean watson did to them on
that certain day and i think they have
the right formula as far as not going
past the quarterback pushing the pocket
that way they'll have certain guys who
oh it looks like they're blitzing but
yet they're just kind of hanging around
the line of scrimmage watching for like
looking for crossers but really watching
kyler murray for when he makes the break
they're there to meet him at that break
point added also
mike like we saw like i mentioned
detroit kind of slowed them down
this miami dolphins defense has got
studs they got three legit corners you
know they got big people in the middle
who can really push the pocket and then
you know guys like van noy and emmanuel
agba are good on the outside they're not
superstar pass rushers but they
understand how to play football take to
the coaching and they are good athletes
in that too so yeah i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna bet on the dolphins defense really
slowing kyler murray down
in his debut last week tuatanga vailo
was 12 for 22 for 93 yards it's an
average of 4.22 yards per attempt his
average throw was 5 yards downfield
lowest of any quarterback last week i
think we all want to see him air it out
a little bit more we all want to see him
have to
play
at a higher level right we don't know
whether he can because he didn't have to
last week because the avalanche came
quickly and before you know it you're in
a different mindset as an offense right
yes well yeah definitely you can't blame
anything for two a lot the game just
unfolded that way last week he didn't
have to do anything he played it the
right way he had the mistake early on
then the defense started playing well
special teams you know scores a
touchdown and then it became hey let's
be conservative they threw a lot of
short passes swings to the back screens
he really only made two legit throws in
the football game the slant touchdown
that was great and he threw a comeback
to his right a little later on you know
both look good he's got good pop in his
feet we'll see where it goes
you know i can't say i sat there and
went oh man the ball flies out of his
arm and man it really pops off the
screen that way no i can't say any of
that right now he does look small out
there i'll say that too so we'll see
where this goes i'm really excited to
evaluate him because you know i was very
much on the fence with him in the draft
process and the other thing i just feel
a little here is
we heard a lot of buzz about herbert and
burrow
through
training camp and things like that to
make you think these teams like what
they're seeing there wasn't buzz about
to it and i'm not saying right or wrong
but i'm just saying in our my experience
and i think you're probably the same way
in the nfl and being around usually when
that type of guy is really popping in
practice and kicking butt you hear buzz
and that gets out through the nfl you
know rumorville and everything like that
and i think that's why i'm also very
intrigued to see the tua thing too
because i feel like we never heard that
buzz this year
hey i recall
my first experience with that dynamic
back in 2003 2004 time frame when i
heard from a source then that the
cowboys really loved this kid
exactly tony robbins and i like who the
hell is tony romo right right right yeah
same mike i knew him only because you
know he was around my you know my age
and things like that i knew the name i
could still remember being in tampa and
john gruden coming in and like talking
about that it was that right there he
had heard from a coach buzzing the nfl
hey i'm hearing this tony romo guys
tearing it up down in dallas like drew
blood so is going to be in trouble
that's how much he's tearing it up and
you were like what tony romo are you
serious so yes that's exactly what i
mean i feel like that never happened
with tua this year and we heard those
type of things with herbert and burrow
and that's why i think there's an extra
level of interest at least for me
pop quiz if i say to you who the hell is
john f kennedy what movie is that from
i don't
i don't know who who is
back to the future man classic moment
classic moment because he travels back
before
kennedy was president and he's looking
for an address he says oh that's over by
john f kennedy drive right the guy who
ultimately becomes his grandpa says who
the hell is john f that's right that's
right that's a good good pull there good
job way to go it's been a while since i
watched that but that's a bingo term
right old movie reference that no one
gets that's a florio bingo term i don't
know look the control room's doing well
enough finding the big guys there it is
you
bingo
yeah uh anarchy um yeah those are uh
yeah that's not your job you have enough
jobs to do don't worry about the control
room's job okay let's move on to actual
football talk carolina panthers three
and five surprising
but they've fallen into a bit of a lull
here they lost to atlanta last thursday
night they get to go to kansas city to
take on patrick mahomes and the chiefs
what's more likely carolina can maybe
grind out the clock keep mahomes on the
sideline drinking gatorade with
christian mccaffrey back if he returns
or teddy bridgewater airs it out to try
to match the chief's offense
i i gotta think
that
if i'm gonna pick one or two there i'm
gonna put teddy bridgewater has to air
it out um
yeah you can make plays on the the the
chiefs defense but i think the chiefs
will realize in this type of matchup too
like they're not going to let them play
a slow death that way
uh
yeah the panthers are a pretty good
running football team they are
definitely
and i think they'll be worried about
yeah we're just going to let them run
the ball
and christian mccaffrey on eight and
seven minute you know drives where they
nickel and dime us to death and then
mahomes doesn't get on the field you
know they've been aggressive for the
most part the whole year and i would
think that continues and spags you know
against these teams who can run the ball
he tends to take chances on the outside
and go okay here we're going to play
aggressive but we're not going to let
you just run the ball down our throats
all day long uh so i i think i'm going
to error on that that teddy bridgewater
has to air it out because they'll see
some favorable matchups with their
receivers where they're just going to go
damn i i can't let them play all three
of these guys man-to-man like this and
we don't take shots down the field so i
would expect some big big numbers this
week from teddy bridgewater and company
the chiefs have allowed 143 rushing
yards per game that's fourth most in the
nfl and mccaffrey is the key here and
sunday will be seven weeks since he was
injured it was way back in week two
against the tampa bay buccaneers he
suffered that ankle injury that was that
sunday where the sky was falling for all
the injuries that happened right out of
the gates as the season began and seven
weeks man that's a bad that's a bad
angle that really is could be gone that
long because there was that mindset and
i remember hearing at the time you know
he's not going to even acknowledge
there's a problem that's not the way
he's wired and he's going to come back
as quickly as he can well you know what
it's smart that the panthers were able
to get him
to wait until he's truly 100 matt rule
the coach of the panthers said wednesday
that he's very hopeful mccaffrey will
play and if they're going to have any
chance in kansas city
they're going to need them and this is
the kind of game where
you can maybe
catch the chiefs peeking ahead not
bringing full focus right they lost to
the raiders this way because there are
some big games on the schedule and then
there are the games on the schedule that
you just kind of look at and you shrug
the problem is when you're the chiefs no
one's shrugging nobody when they face
you you're getting the best of every
team and this is the measuring stick
game yeah right right we've talked about
that dynamic in the past the chiefs are
now the measuring stick and they're
going to be a measuring stick for the
carolina panthers all right ravens five
and two colts five and two ravens are
going to be without a bunch of defensive
players who are in the covet 19
high risk category though i think they
they may i don't again i don't the math
i never understand the math i think
maybe they get some of the guys back
saturday morning right right so they're
not going to be as ready as they would
be what's more likely philip rivers
isn't sacked by the ravens defense or
baltimore sacks him
multiple times two or more times what's
more like i'm going to say multiple
times i am one thing i'll say first off
is i was really impressed with the way
yannick and gawkway looked on that
ravens defense so that gives him another
guy you know phillip rivers
he will stand in the pocket and of
course you know
take some time in there to maybe let a
play develop down the field and i think
also with baltimore ravens and their
ability to cover and do some confusing
things on the back end that'll lead him
to hold the ball a few times you know
and i i would think there's going to be
a few moments in the game where yeah the
colts are not going to be able to just
rely on the run game and they're going
to have to drop back and move the ball
that way to where i'm i'm gonna go with
baltimore you know getting multiple
sacks on him
phillip rivers has only been sacked
seven times in seven games so that's an
average of one per game ravens defense
has 24 sacks in seven games and for six
of them they didn't have yannick and
gawkway bears titans this one is
compelling to me because both teams are
desperate they both lost two games in a
row they get together in nashville
what's more likely tennessee gets
multiple sacks something they've had a
hard time doing this year or they
disappoint versus another battered
offensive line that chicago line has
been decimated by injuries by covid and
nick foles has been sacked nine times
in the team's last two games chris
this is this one's hard too man this one
might be the hardest one we've had yet
where i just look at it because yeah
there's the the tennessee titans her you
know pass rush challenged a little bit
they were better last week but that damn
joe burrow got out about seven sacks so
you know that's that's the the issue
there
um the bears are not really a hold the
ball let's wait for down the field
throwing type team either this is where
i struggle it because you know as we see
nick foles a lot of the times when he's
thrown it's an empty set or it's four
wide receivers and they throw the ball
and get the ball out of their hands
pretty quickly that way
um i'm going to go with tennessee gets
multiple sacks this week i am because of
the covet issues because it's just not a
very talented offensive line and then i
think also the fact that
i think the titans will be able to error
on a little bit on blitzing
messing with the pass game because it's
not a great run game you have to worry
about defending when the chicago bears
and i think that'll lead them to finding
a few creative ways to get after foals
who can at times you know because he's
so big and he is good at throwing with
pressure around him hold the ball a hair
too long so i'm going to go with it this
week even though i'm not feeling real
comfortable
judy and clowning knee injury he has had
that injury for several weeks no
practice for him on wednesday last week
he didn't practice wednesday or thursday
he was limited on friday he played he's
got zero sacks i know this year for the
titans no zero zero and they cut vic
beasley this week he had zero sacks that
was a wasted nine and a half million
dollars although they're hoping that
someone will pick up his contract on
waivers and save them 1.85 million so
that that titan it's just weird to see a
team
that has that smash mouth running game
and has that old school vibe that can't
get to the quarterback on a consistently
no it is they've got seven sacks in
seven games yeah it really is and
they're they're in a tough spot too
because they have creative blitzes and
things like that but they haven't been
able to you know hold up playing
man-to-man i think as well as they would
like either so that's where vrabel and
company are a little in a tough spot
clowney again you know just to echo this
because i know you know this but i just
like to you know zero sacks but man
there's been a lot of games where i mean
he's all over the place he's disruptive
as hell um but yeah pure soccer sack you
know sac assassin or anything like that
that's not his forte there and you know
it is about disruption and just pushing
the pocket and things like that with him
we have yet to convince the elias sports
bureau to make ef up the play an
official stat so we have not been we'll
get there
we'll get there all right steelers
cowboys one of the great rivalries inner
conference rivalries it's special when
they play not as special this year
because the cowboys stink it's going to
be garrett gilbert or cooper rush
playing quarterback for the cowboys on
sunday what's more likely the game is
decided at the end of the first quarter
or we actually have reason to watch in
the second half unrelated to over under
or whether or not the steelers cover the
14 point spread well i mean there's a
wide gap here but i'm gonna i mean
i'm gonna go with the first one gamers
decide at the end of the first quarter i
i am i mean the steelers
i mean they're foaming at the mouth
every week i think they're a team that's
you know feeling the vibes of how good
they are and they're going to relish
this and i don't think you're going to
catch them sleeping in fact i think
they're going to go
man this is going to be fun we're going
to beat the crap out of this football
team like i think they're going to enjoy
it they're going to be like man i think
we could actually pulverize them into
the ground i think that's and that i
would expect
this to be
yes the cowboys come out and try to run
and have a few things with ezekiel
elliott there's no chance that happens
the steelers will be ready
and they're gonna force eventually that
those those quarterbacks into some
passing situations they're gonna turn
the ball over i just i think this will
certainly be over by halftime but i'll
take the end of the first quarter for
this exercise here
ben roethlisberger's 0-2 all-time at a t
stadium one game was against the packers
super bowl 45 the other game was a
regular season contest against the
cowboys and this is where being the
cowboys
hurts the cowboys when they're bad we
talked about the chiefs being that
measuring stick type of a team
for
any other franchise they're facing them
because the chiefs are so good right the
cowboys because they're america's team
because there's that extra sizzle that's
flash that great stadium you you go
there
and you don't step into the trap
of they stink you go there and you're
motivated it's a big stage even if the
cowboys are windless it's a big stage
and that makes it even more likely that
steelers won't won't stumble and 8-0 is
looking pretty good for them all right
sunday night football game of the week
saints bucks five and two new orleans
six and two tampa bay what is more
likely
tom brady at 561 career touchdown passes
maintains the all-time record after this
game or drew brees who has 560
takes it back from it yeah i'm gonna go
with tom brady here i am you know tom
brady is just
his arm is still too explosive i mean
that's the biggest thing
and of course they have the explosive
weapons to go on the outside and do that
and then added to that i mean tom
brady's team has the number one defense
in football you know and they can get
after the quarterback and they can cover
you man-to-man you know and they can do
some creative things that way
and they don't let up a lot of big plays
you know that's that's the issue on the
other side too is not only like yeah
breezing on that offense can't you know
make a lot of big plays but
the biggest issue with the saints is
they're letting up big plays by the
handful every game i mean it's amazing
with the saints you know there are top
ten defense in yards allowed they go
through series of just dominating where
you just go whoa is this the best
defense in football and then all of a
sudden they'll have three or four plays
out of 10 where it's like they're 60
yards there's 40 yards what the hell
happened so uh from that aspect that's
why i gotta go with brady there
yeah i agree with you too and you know
how much
do you believe
brady is pissed off that his first game
as a buccaneer was against the saints
and it didn't go well and he had to pick
six and he got called out how much of
that i mean he doesn't need any extra
motivation he's got plenty yeah do you
think he has a little something more for
this one because of the way week one
turned out i definitely do and the fact
that drew brees is over there and
everything like that like listen both of
these guys are paying attention to this
record you can guarantee that and this
is personal to them and i would bet you
it's more personal to drew brees because
he's like wait this was my one thing
i had this like you got everything else
let me have my damn thing and that's
where you know brady's amazing and you
know the way brady looks i mean
he's not stopping after this year
there's no reason to stop i mean it's
it's still one of the best throwers in
football you know he's amazing that way
and you know and again where i'll just
say i don't even think it's close in
this discussion anyways is tom brady
played up in new england all those years
in that weather in december and was
still throwing those touchdown passes
like that and to me that's where it's
like worth an extra 100 touchdowns
compared to what drew brees did and
that's where you know i i think brady's
amazing
here's what i want to know yeah i want
to know if hall of fame president david
baker is going to be there with a sheet
of paper
that he will
take from tom brady and give to drew
brees wouldn't that be great
freeze passes him so baker goes and
takes the sheet of paper from brady and
gives it a breeze and then brady passes
brees and david baker says hold on a
second takes the sheet of paper back
from brady and breeze and gives it to
brady we're saying that because there
was some record and it seems like every
time drew billy brees plays in prime
time he sets some sort of a record and
they handed him a sheet of paper i think
it was laminated which makes it a little
bit better i guess when he set one of
the all-time records but yeah you're
right brees is the guy who's the stat
machine breeze is the guy who is
destined to have all the all-time
records but uh here's the problem for
him tom brady's going to play longer
than he does yeah so it's kind of fun to
watch it go back and forth but unless
brees is going to play one more year
tom's going to own this thing when it's
all said and done yeah it's i mean again
this is where tom
you know again i think he'll always be
underrated for his physical ability do i
think he's a little overrated in a
little ways yes you've heard me say that
definitely yeah no i know i don't think
he's the greatest of all time i don't i
think he's amazing i mean he's certainly
one of the three or four best of all
time he got put in a great situation
you know that
and you know it kind of accumulated into
hey i'm the greatest quarterback of all
time but i think we can put some other
quarterbacks here in the top five we put
them in new england they'd have a lot of
hardware too and i'm not trying to take
disrespect from them that way but you
know brady i've never seen anybody be
this consistently good for this long
that is where
nobody is going to challenge tom brady
at least i don't expect them to in our
lifetime i mean because it's really
amazing and especially as you've
mentioned before it's like two different
hall of fame careers he went through a
lull there in 2009 10 and 11 and even 12
where it wasn't great football yeah they
won and they were still a good team and
things like that but man after that on
to cincinnati he changed his crap around
and he's been like
you know it was like a revert back to
brady in the first five six years of his
career and he's been phenomenal really
ever since
i think it was on to cincinnati combined
with the drafting of jimmy garoppolo yes
right fueled the second half right his
career and and created the argument that
you could have two hall of fame busts
with tom brady's name on them pre-2008
post 2010.
look it's fun to do
the
what would have happened if quarterbacks
were in different spots
and we've had the conversation about gee
how many super bowls would they have won
with aaron rodgers over the last 15
years i i still come back to the
question
of whether or not aaron rodgers is wired
to put up with bill belichick
over the long haul
brady was able to do it for 20 years
chris i don't think aaron rodgers could
do it for 20 years well i i don't know
you know again i if aaron rodgers is
drafted by them and gets into that
environment from day one aaron rodgers
was brought up in an environment that
hey it's brett favre he's the king of
the team look whatever he says we do
hey oh aaron rodgers you're now the you
took over you're the king wait you put
two good seasons hey king of the team
aaron so that's you know that's where
it's hard for me to differentiate that
way you know i i don't think aaron
rodgers would have an issue there i
don't you know again you know i think
again peyton manning you know i'm sure
he's a pain in the butt too in a lot of
ways but i think if he was drafted by
new england again it'd be really damn
good results and he'd be kicking butt
there too so i i i don't know mike
that's a tough one a lot of that is said
or comes about by oh i was drafted here
this is the culture i don't know any
different and that's how it kind of
molds these guys going forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports